hey guys I'm Bryce sander I'm Denny
direct oh now it's been a minute since
all the queens of RuPaul's Drag Race all
starts to have been in the same room
together they're back and they're only
dishing to ET about what we can expect
from the reunion
so reunited and it feels so so good it
feels beyond good it feels dumb hard
[ __ ] West Side mother hakuna matata
it's the reunion means no worries no
breasteses falling out it's always super
fun to watch it as a fan and it's
especially like being part of it and
like having it been over a year ago
like seeing all the new things it's
great you know I love seeing the girls
and you get to rehash everything you
know all-stars we've all been friends
before this and it's not like a new
season so it's all of our friends we get
to hang out there you go is there drama
at this reunir special are you expecting
the drama I mean anything would rank
Queens I mean come on drama queen
Oh drama is inherent it's like it's
woven into the fabric of reality look at
these nails as soon as I would hear them
lay start bitching I would check myself
out of the whole situation yeah cuz I'm
there for you know I'm not there to be
Petty and like I'm drama I'm there for a
crown yeah it's like a family reunion I
mean that thing just look we're
revisiting something that we did over a
year ago do you understand what that
means
365 days of not knowing what's gonna
happen
fefe costume drama and did not show up
today I think she's very talented he is
a creative artiste because there's so
much talent and potential I think that
he's struggling internally with
something III don't know there's
something there because it's looking
dark she made a decision and she's stuck
with it if it wasn't good for her
then good for her you know she stuck to
her guns I got choices have you guys
buried the hatchet so to speak I think
it's one sided I don't have a hatchet
toward town I said I needed to say on
the show we've worked together since the
show I didn't think there was an issue
but a say it looks like he's having
issues with several
so it's disappointing and you know there
were 10 of us and you know seriously
like some of these queens did it get the
best shake you know like Coco Montrese
went home first and darling she's here
today looking stunning fulfilling her
obligations and being lovely about it so
like I think that's really classy and
really professional love y'all
John Panikkar it was really a season
full of like redemption did you come in
feeling like you had something to prove
oh my god yes did you watch season 5 I
know I know
yes um I I came in proven you know
wanting to prove that I could play the
game as a you know just as a competitor
and not as somebody who was going into
the played mind games to try to you know
overstep the other people so I felt like
I did that I felt like it came off that
way and I've been having so much more
fun this time around you think everybody
got Redemption I don't I mean we all get
to be on TV again so that's pretty great
that's like worth the price of admission
I think I didn't come into it trying to
get any kind of redemption but I
definitely have a lot more validation
with how well I'm doing I mean I didn't
really go into a trying to redeem
anything because I was kind of cool on
season 2 you are I definitely
accomplished what I came to accomplish
which is just you know show people what
I have and talents I've acquired since
season 2 and all that good stuff yeah
it's my favorite show to begin with so
like whether I'm on it or not I'm there
on the dot at the time and nobody better
speak to me while it's on the air
RuPaul's Drag Race is really a journey
of courageous stories it's a movement
coming back this season I told myself
girl look here it is worry less laugh
more and I did that it's interesting
interesting well I can't say too much
this opportunity what you why should we
tune in you didn't look like that well
cuz I'll be there that's all you have to
tune there you go
thanks for watching guys let us know
your favorite part of the whole season
below also let us know what was your
favorite look of the entire season and
be sure to subscribe to et's youtube
channel